members of the economic block known as
bricks are meeting for a second date in
Johannesburg the alliance is made up of
Brazil Russia India China and South
Africa leaders are looking to present
Brooks as a counterweight to the West
the war on Ukraine Russia's growing
isolation and global economic turmoil
dominated the first day of talks on
Monday well let's take a closer look at
Brooks the leaders of Brazil Russia
India and China originally made up the
grouping which held its first summit in
Russia in mid-2009 South Africa joined
in 2010. the block is pushing to be a
new global voice representing a quarter
of the world's economy a fifth of all
trade and nearly half of the global
population it wants to counter what it
considers a unilateral approach in
geopolitics but stresses it's not
anti-west these are challenging times
however China and South Africa's
economies have slowed Russia has invaded
Ukraine and India seeks to balance
relations with both Moscow and
Washington but more than 20 20 countries
have employed to join brics including
Argentina Saudi Arabia and Iran well
let's get more on this our correspondent
Fami the Miller is joining us live from
Johannesburg so what's on the agenda
today farmer the summit has seeing the
most International interest it has in
years
I think the agenda for the rest of the
Summit is very much linked to everything
that you've mentioned around key issues
that this Brix block is trying to deal
with and I think primarily also
economies of these individual member
states and recovery after the covid-19
pandemic and essentially how these
members can help each other across the
African continent there appears to be
increasing interest in the block and
member states of the block are equally
interested in expanding across this
continent and developing infrastructure
developing economies boosting economies
and providing a platform where these
countries can grow and ultimately
potentially through the new development
bank which provides an attractive option
for developing nations with regard to
more favorable
conditions around loans and investment
if expansion is also on the agenda
related to at least 23 countries that
have applied to join this block and also
the issue of what's been called the
dollarization where these countries want
to rely on their individual currencies
more move away from the dollar in terms
of trade there's been talk around a
brics currency but there's been no
consensus on that and it's also not
clear whether that in itself is
desirable for these member states so if
it's about just using local currencies
more uh to to move away from the dollar
so certainly a sort of independence from
Western dominance and also expansion of
the block and boosting the economies of
existing and potential members okay
finally there's a big Ambitions a lot of
interest from other countries to join
but how much do we expect the group to
achieve at the summit when there are
clear differences between members such
as India and China and also differences
between members relationship with the US
and the West just to name a few
divergences
thanks
when a country like South Africa for
example in in the brics block is a
country that's trying to balance these
interests between uh it's it's its
investment within brics its relationship
with countries like Russia and China and
then balancing that with its
relationship with the West with the US
and the European Union and when you talk
about these sort of Divergent
characteristics of these countries
that's a problem for South Africa where
it's trying to balance something like
that but ultimately we're looking at
countries like Russia and China who do
want to move away from that Western
dominance and this is something that
might bring these countries together how
effective it could be I suppose is
questionable and uh critics the harsh
critics have said that brics hasn't
achieved very much others have said
that's incorrect that the brexit brics
uh block is brought together a number of
key countries like South Africa which
provides for bricks a gateway to this
continent where there are massive
resources and Africa also provides trade
routes sea routes as especially towards
East Africa that could be very
beneficial and also looking at the
expansion what would be key for a
country like Russia is that prisons
within the United Nations General
Assembly where it would take up the
largest proportional that at least 28
percent so when it comes to issues of
voting this is where countries like
Russia China could benefit so for the
countries involved there is a lot at
stake and it's likely that there could
be some solid concrete resolutions
towards the end of the summer taking
place in Johannesburg by the end of
Thursday all right farming thank you
very much for that farm in the Miller
joining us live from Johannesburg